he was really all wrought up and you
could just sense how much anger he had
and so he was really trying to dominate
and then literally stalk me around the
stage and I would just feel this
presence behind Hillary Clinton is
speaking out about that second
presidential debate on The Ellen
DeGeneres Show just one day after Donald
Trump said any women claiming he
sexually assaulted them are lying these
events never ever happened now an old
interview the presidential hopeful and
his kids did with Howard Stern has
surfaced here's what the 70 year old
said back in 2006 this comes as a new
Huffington Post report claims Donald
bashed Khloe Kardashian on set of The
Celebrity Apprentice back in 2009 making
quote nasty comments about her weight
and looks calling her a piglet well we
talked about her time on that show
earlier this year with Chelsea Handler I
just didn't care to do Celebrity
Apprentice
I don't know why just like it wasn't for
me I hated every minute of it
you